hey guys what's up this is andrew for
consensus.com so
as you can see guys i'm back right now
in hong kong but i'm not in my place i'm
in the quarantine hotel
i'm gonna stay here for two weeks
unfortunately
uh it could have been one week if i had
some antibody tests you know but it
this stuff is just so complicated so
anyways i'm stuck here guys for two
weeks
and of course i'm gonna take some time
to to be on my discord channel first so
i spent a lot of time there
yesterday and trying to you know give
some insight about amc price action that
is not looking good
i'm going to here make a full update
about amc i'm also going to make an
update about jimmy
and yeah i have to say that i don't feel
so good yes to be honest but i don't
have to copy it
and i feel good enough to make an update
on amc so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys as usual i'm gonna start
by reminding you what i was saying in my
last video
so in my last video i was basically here
seeing it was like this guys
so we bottomed at 38 38.7
and we had this huge strong rebound of
25
which was looking very good with some
strong associated volume
so this could be our reversal that we're
waiting for the fifth wave
in these situations usually those you
know
sharp moves up they don't retrace a lot
that's why
i was telling you guys that if we break
45
and i know that 45 is quite high but
when you have this kind of strong
rebound you know after such you know
bearish moves
here we lost you know 35
then the move up should be very strong
otherwise it's going to fail
it's usually happening like this i was
looking here for some support levels and
i found this trend line
and i told you guys we had also the
moving averages on the first time frame
and i told you guys that if we close
below 45 here
we would probably go to 24. why i said
24 guys because i knew that
here if we are not able to hold the
price
at this level which is no surprise guys
a few
level when i measure this first wave you
know it's the
38.2 percent was 45.5 so it was roughly
the level i gave you
and maximum we should go to 44th so i
have all this area where i wanted to see
some support
and some reactions we didn't see it and
it's with no surprise that we got back
to 38 and we
broke 38 yesterday once again guys for
those who want
more insight about the amc price action
or whatever gme bitcoin
go on my discord channel guys i put
there a lot of uh
information i mean i do my best to post
some daily information
especially at the open i'm in hong kong
right now so you guys know that we have
12 hours difference with the united
states
where amc is training so i i told you
guys yesterday that
i don't think 38 would hold for the same
reason that i just told you guys that if
we break
45 to me it means that the the
correction is not done
and i i don't see 28 holding and it
didn't hold
so right now what are my different
scenarios so
something i want to talk about guys on
my discord there was some of you
that were telling me oh look on the five
minutes time frame all 15 minutes time
frame i have a lot of divergences
and you know they were trying to use
those divergences to
actually uh predict the reversal
so let's see actually yeah you can see
that here you had a lot of divergences
all right the magazine making new
lows with the price action going lower
all the time but
careful guys you know basically you can
you have the regular divergence this is
a regular divergence
and you have the hidden divergences so
regular divergences are going to show
you a reversal so
if you have a reversal you have a
breakout so i prefer to wait for the
breakout and associate it with my
divergence
otherwise a simple bearish regular
divergence is not enough for me
to actually decide that the reversal
coming is my preferred scenario and here
you can see that those differences were
not enough so what you're looking for
guys here i sent
this as well on my discord guys it's
like this trend line needs to be broken
somehow so you know something like this
this is what you guys want to see
so here once again we have a nice
bullish regular divergence all right
let me show you the divergences once
again so let me show you guys once again
what i'm talking about here so the
regular bullish divergence is this one
yes so basically
the market is making new lows but the
momentum
is shifting up all right so you can use
macd rsi or stochastic
and this means that the bears are out of
steam out of energy and that the bulls
are probably going to
take back control soon but once again we
had
those all the way down guys so i always
prefer to associate
those regular bullish divergences or
regular burst divergences with the
breakout so wait for the breakout
here so right now it's around the 35
area and this would mean that we would
go to the 42 area
you can do the same thing on the higher
time frame guys you
zoom out and here for now you see we
don't have the divergence but if we go
here we would probably have a divergence
and you need to wait for the breakout of
this trendline all right
this is the yellow trend line here by
the way i hope my cursor
is big enough for you guys i couldn't
change it in white but i put it bigger
so i hope everyone can see what i'm
doing here and this trend line guys okay
this is what we need to break to confirm
that the correction
is definitely complete because if you
have a breakout here we could still go
lower
so i'm coming to my different scenarios
now that we broke 38
what can happen we have two different
scenarios
either we rebound at 32 to the 33
so let me show you how i found those i
just checked this so once again i sent
this exact thing in my discord guys so
please
go there you're going to have a lot of
information there are a lot of people
that
you know are very qualified in technical
analysis so i'm not the only one sharing
my analysis and we just discussed this
and this morning we were discussing
what are the different scenarios for the
c wave
and you use this staff guys in the
elliott wave book that you can find on
google
and basically it's saying that you can
measure so you use fib
extension you measure from zero to three
and you apply to the bottom of the force
right and the typical ratios are
61.8 percent one or one point six one
eight so the 1.618 goes to eight so this
is of the table guys it's too long
it would mean that we have a very
extended fifth it's nearly impossible
here
so the two realistic scenarios are we go
to 0.618 0.618.34
so 24 is a very strong level but i'm
gonna
come to this very soon you're gonna see
that it's unfortunately not my preferred
scenario
and the next one is 24. 78.6
is not one of those guys so basically we
have the choice between 34
and 24 so we could have already
completed this fixed wave that can go
here and then we bounce back and we do
one
three four five and of course we go to
the 100
135 area all right so
my first wave would be here let me get
rid of this for a sec
but guys look when i connect the bottom
of the first wave with the bottom of the
third wave
it gives me a support trend line a
downward sloping trend line that is
acting as support and this has been
broken on the forwards not confirmed yet
but guys this is
breaking here right actually it's
confirmed all right we have the breakout
here and we break here
for me between 38 and 24 is a no man's
land that's what i said as well on my
discord
and that's why i don't believe 24 would
hold unfortunately but i might be wrong
here
it's a 50 50 scenario actually maybe 60
40
i'm a bit maybe bearish here because i
can see that something is missing you
know you can hear try to count
in the fifth wave you should have five
waves as well it's very tough to be
honest it's very tough
i can do something like this one two and
this to me look maybe like a three
you know maybe a four or five it's it's
very difficult to do but
i have the feeling that something is
missing that we might break this and
then go over
i don't know so just be careful guys
it's not because we break 35
here that we are safe we need to break
35 so what you can do if you want to
reload you can wait for this breakout
buy here
if we go here you're good but careful if
we break
34 it would be roughly the level you
bought you need to exit your position i
know you guys don't like to sell
i'm just giving you some day trading
techniques here this is what i would do
and i'm going to be allowed to do this
very soon i'm trying to set up my
accesses and see if i i'm allowed
actually to trade live
in front of you guys on youtube for
example and this is what i would do i
would wait for a breakout here i would
buy here
maybe even sell a bit of chassis and buy
bite back here because
we have two areas of resistance here
that we need to go
above in order to be almost hundred
percent sure that we're in this fifth
wave
so i'll repeat my first scenario is this
one we bounce back right away my second
scenario is we go here to 24
and once again guys don't be afraid you
know 24 is a normal
corrective level i remind you guys that
false wave they like to retrace to the
top of the third
or the bottom of the fourth preceding
wave counting
which is here 37 where we went and
24 so i wouldn't be that surprised that
we go to 24 it would not change much
the only thing it would change it's my
target so my target would be a bit lower
obviously in this situation because i
use fibs
for the same this exact same way i did
it with you guys here i measured from
one to three
and i applied to the bottom of the force
so my level would be
and i go to the 1.618 relation and i
have 88
128 as levels so maybe 88 maybe 128
but in both cases 24 would be an amazing
level to buy
i'm sorry i was not very clear in my
last video i was saying that here it
might get ugly
i was thinking about another scenario
that this is just one
we have a two three four and five all
right but we are very far from this
scenario
and for now my preferred scenario if we
go to 24 is
a strong bounce back and then we need to
see what is happening around the 28th
area this would be very important but
first
from 24 95 chance we go back to 38
then here question do are we going lower
or are we
actually doing the fifth so it's going
to be a very interesting question
for now we're not there yet we are at
32.5 in after hours
so let's see if we manage to hold this
level or not i think unfortunately we're
gonna go lower which is actually a very
nice opportunity
so let's see and one more thing i wanted
to show you guys so i told you that for
the regular bearish
bullish or bearish divergences you need
to wait for a breakout to associate it
with the divergence
and for the hidden divergence that we
had here all the way up guys
in the correction for example here we
had one hidden dimension so market
making
higher lows with the melody making lower
lows so here
and still we failed to go higher but in
this situation
you don't wait for the breakout you use
the breakout as a stop loss so here it
would be
at this level at the 48 level so this is
just a smooth technique try to remember
this
use regular bullish or bearish it
doesn't change anything the regular
divergences those two
use them after breakout because it's a
reversal pattern
and the hidden divergences use the
breakout as a stop loss because there
are continuation
signals so guys now i want to talk about
gme in the same video because i can't
post you know one video
every two days for both stocks and a lot
of you asking me to
do analysis every day for one and the
other one so the only option i have is
to make one video containing
two of them so let's get into it all
right so here guys
same thing it doesn't look good so let
me remind you what i was telling you in
my previous videos guys
so basically i was connecting here
due to lows and i had level at 117 and i
was telling you guys that
this is the level below which i don't
feel good at all so
let me remind you what we had here we
had this strong breakout guys and this
you need to keep in mind because this
event is not forgotten by anyone
yet all right we had this huge breakout
at the 200 level then we went to 340
we got rejected as expected and what is
not expected
is what is happening here all right a
lot of selling pressure
that to me is not usual there are a lot
of players investing in those stocks and
some of them probably collaborate
together
we have the dark pools so like i said i
don't like to talk about manipulation
not because i don't believe in it of
course i do believe in manipulation of
course i know that there is a lot of
manipulation in gamestop amc
and in many many other stocks as well
it's just that you know some people talk
about it a bit too much and just say
manipulation each time this you move
down
i'm not like that you know i try to do a
clean reasoning and if nothing
explains what i'm having then i call it
manipulation
here maybe we can talk about
manipulation because
usually it's not happening like this and
i have something that really looks weird
i'm going to show it to you and we had
the exact same phenomenon on amc
so basically i'm coming to my scenario
very soon but the first thing
i want to show you guys is that here why
was i bullish so the first reason is
that we have this huge breakout yes that
is
you know a perfect breakout with
gigantic volumes then correct which is
totally normal so for me this was a one
i was expecting a two that arrived and
then three and four and five
i like to take the retracement and
usually we don't go below the 61.8
i mean we usually go to the 61.8 so
maybe slightly below but usually we
don't go
below the 78.6 retracement here 170
funny it's the same level as the
trendline that is connected to two lows
here and here is giving to me
and what happened yesterday guys we
broke it we broke it
let's check the volume quickly it's very
important to know if there was a lot of
volume or not
volume was low but still we broke it all
right so
what does it telling us it's telling us
that if you use for example
so i like to use uh hidden divergences
as continuation
signals that tell me that ongoing trend
is going to keep happening so here for
example between a
and the c wave you connect the lows you
can see that the market is going higher
during the same time the macd here is
making new lows
all right so this is as you guys know a
hidden bullish divergence right it's
this one
but once again just like i explained for
amc when you use the signals i like to
use the breakout as
a safety line as a stop loss so that's
why here
if we break this level i would be as a
day trader out of this trade
just below this level all right because
this is invalidating the
bullish heat and divergence that i had
here but look you guys how funny it is
so basically
this stuff would have made me
sold so on the daily time frame i would
have wait for a confirmation only four
hours
so let's be totally honest and here you
know i would have
exited my position as a daytrader i
would have done that if i follow my
rules and i would be out of this trade
now i know the situation i know it's
game stop so to be honest i don't have
game stop shots yet
no imc because i was not allowed to
trade on my personal account as a pro
trader but
very soon i'm going to be able to have
some and here if i had some i would of
course
not sell it i would not feel good but i
would keep it because
i know what happened with amc yes look
exact same situation
remember this trend line connecting the
two recent highs before the strong move
up we had here
and the exact same thing happened guys
we will trace a bit too much
actually this first wave all right we
went below the 78.6 percent
and look what has happened here we had
this regular bullish divergence
so on the flowers so this is amc job
guys so just for you to follow
okay the daily we have it so here you
can see that you have the market making
new the macd making new lows with the
market making higher lows oh funny
exactly like on gamestop and when i do
this trendline
here it arrives at the exact same level
guys it was
night 80 and i remember this time i was
telling you guys we
will not break it because i was very
sure as i had this
breakout here that we would go higher
and do one two three four five
so i remember that day i was not feeling
good guys
because i wanted to give you something
that is clean and this was not clean
this was messy
so here what i think is happening guys
is that hedge funds know
that a lot of people use technical
analysis follow guys that know about
technical analysis like
me and those guys they have no other
choice than telling you the truth
here that this breakout invalidates the
hidden bullish divergence all right
let me show you again the hidden
buddhist
divergence this one so market making new
low and the momentum shifting down so
basically the bears are not able
to take more ground and
usually when you have this you don't
break this line you don't
all right let me tell you that i've been
doing this a lot of years
and usually it doesn't happen and it's
so funny that it happened on amc
and that's right after we had this very
strong move up and that right now yes
the exact same thing
is happening on gamestop and so what
happened on amc
we re-tested this trendline all right
you know that after breakout the market
likes to read the speed of the breakout
level or the breakup trend line
here we have already retested the
breakout level that was around 200
and we are now heading to retest the
breakout trendline that is at 143
so guys i'm giving you my preferred
scenario it's very clear
is that we go 243 doing an abc
completing our correction here that
would be a w
x y yeah w x y
w x y let me put it in
maybe think not very clear but anyway
you can see it the wxy here would be
complete we go to 143
and we strongly bounce back guys this is
my scenario
i'm calling it i'm waiting for it once
again as a pro trailer i should be out
of this thread let's be honest
all right but here i'm giving you my
personal feeling
is that something is tricking us guys
just the way it did on amc and just
right after that we had a strong rebound
here so basically hedge funds
knew the signal was coming because they
know technical analysis and they
probably
you know managed to destroy the signal
by breaking this trend line you know
it's not that complicated
to get a few percent for big hatch fans
on the stock like amc
game stuff it's actually very easy so
they break the signals so
you know apes basically don't buy but
apes
both anyway on amc so let's see what
happens on vm stop guys let's see what
happens i'm very curious to know
if this is going to hold if this breaks
yes i need to tell you
as well the alternative scenario if this
breaks as usual guys
we go to the previous levels so 110
would be the next level
all right but i believe strongly it's
going to hold and i believe strongly
that my scenario that is here for a
couple of months
is the right one so let's find out guys
so that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget guys to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to floor i see you
guys